right so this is the season premiere of
season two scared welcome to your dreamy
sets I figure it's my favorite that and
karaoke is about sounding good about
sounding terrible together are my two
favorite lines today and there are a lot
of good lines in this one um this is an
episode where uh we don't quite see what
stand is up to but we know it takes time
and he gives dipper his book back but
he's made copies of all the pages and
everything but now ancient officials or
government agent official bad secret
agent people come and drink power one of
them voiced by Ron Swanson or according
to this key Virginia which is now what
the opening backwards is the whispering
at the end which is an hour kind of
decoding method I guess they use for the
creds whose use me I also get coughing
sneeze um so no yes so uh Keys instead
they had this grand reopening of the
mystery shack and Mabel really wants to
do her karaoke and dipper really wants
the agents to look into what's going on
wants to share his book accidentally
raises the dead as it happens and
zombies running all over the place
soos gets turned to a zombie and he's
probably the funniest Sambi ever yeah
sorry dude just want to eat your brain
I'm certain these guys I'm like a genius
Marco zombie makes us look cooler more
red okay I taught them how to get into
the fuse box I love what they throw a
disco ball a bit Sally they're lighting
up great um so uh and they find out the
one way to defeat them is through a was
it a three-part harmony and so they do
they get the karaoke patrol alpha ghosts
and this name for a band ever I was just
hoping they think don't stop on believin
um but the song you know but yeah this
song was pretty funny
Oh Dan I'm putting on my best dress
ya know it's my kids it's dippers OTL
I'm putting
my best read this is stupid I never
agreed to that name
boys are up or hey the only wrinkly
person that's gonna be right so they
defeat the zombies and then the agents
get out of the pit they say they're
gonna do more research on this place um
so yeah just a good start a part of me
is kind of disappointed that we didn't
even that we didn't get even more about
what Stan was putting together down
there but at the same time it's it's
respect for the mystery I get it you
guys stretch it out it's not like they
don't have other little clues throughout
this season um I'm gonna lead to that
she-male from The Crying Game selling it
and there's still a lot of lot of stuff
that's dropped in here uh the first
thing I know is he says I've been
waiting 30 years after I remember what
the date on the calendar was in that
room wasn't like 1982
furry something like that about 30 years
yeah so so that thing I won this when it
aired or what it came out yeah right
right now it's uh yeah well yeah I could
a 2014 year could than 84 I mean roughly
around 30 years that's when the calendar
says I mean there might be off a year or
two but um when he puts on the glove to
throw the switch it has six fingers
which is interesting uh the first I just
wanna point out the free pizza guy cuz a
lot of people are like he doesn't always
have that shirt it's I think it's like
one episode that I'm convinced they just
forgot to animate it on him the free
pizza like cuz I was like I love that
running joke then like oh I thought
there was because they're advertising
free pizza when there's not the guy that
has the shirt free pizza walks away and
he always has a shirt so I'm just I'm
convinced as an MH mistake but um when
dipper is looking over all the the signs
you know like Waze discovered there's a
picture of a professor on there and I
don't think we've come across yet uh I
think might be in the next one and then
yeah at the very end we have a lead into
the again to the with the staircase and
the tree which is actually in this next
episode so I'm that that's very early on
so it's not giving anything away um so a
lot of cool stuff
and oh and the code of course I was at
the hammering down but uh was the man
downstairs is very clever can he hide
his plans forever so yeah this is a good
start to many funny jokes I need too
many funny lines I mean they just kept
hitting it hitting and hitting and it's
like now I'm trying to remember that
it's like crabs are so many um damn
they're just down those at them my two
favorites like it's there at the karaoke
and the welcome to your dreams one um
yeah and I love what uh I just love this
can show where it's like you can in this
one you can have zombies and the last
one you can have dinosaurs in the next
one you can have gremlins well gnomes I
don't know and I love having everyone
it's always like something different and
it's just it gets you excited every show
you're going to see something along
those lines like the creepy supernatural
so your thoughts I feel naked without my
Mabel sweater Jesus Christ you know
you're sitting there like really quiet
I'm just like he's building up to
something I'm gonna finish my thought
and then he's gotta deliver on way he's
gonna deliver I think was driving you
insane I I shouldn't wear it anymore
because like the Ring of Power it drove
me mad but yeah I feel well doesn't feel
right doesn't feel right now but for the
good of everyone
I won't wear it because with great
sweaters comes great responsibility
yeah great you know you just guaranteed
everyone the countess would be like it
cuz that's how they talk when they type
I know this I've seen it it's really
white and the only type with one finger
at a time too
with one going down so why are you gonna
pick on our own fans I I don't know I
think I'm just imitating like one person
I'm sure is out there who has some sort
of condition that requires them to write
I'm sorry that one person who does that
I think I need a break I think my
sweater-wearing days are done for a
little while but when the time is right
and the people are ready the sweater
will return summerween summerween no
earlier than that we still have
Christmas coming
and it is a Christmas I am wondering cuz
I haven't seen all season two then I
think there's like one episode I haven't
seen yet uh and I almost am wondering if
they ever do like uh uh summer must like
economist how do you do a Christmas
episode of gravity falls
well like Creek hmm I'm trying so
October so you need two months of summer
wins yeah I guess at the end of August
you could do that but if summer Wiens
near the beginning of summer then yeah I
don't know um I would love to get you
know my obsession with Christmas I would
love to see in gravity falls Christmas
but I don't know that's gonna happen
um but it'd be amazing I will say this
sweater watch it was a watermelon this
time yes I actually that's where I was
pretty awesome of all the sweaters this
probably my favorite one because it
takes you a second it's like it Reds
black dots and green the phone what is
that all watermelon I like that once
again what I love about this show is
like Mabel is seen kind of is like the
the the dopey one the sort of goofy
silly one but once again she's
completely right dipper what is the one
thing I told you not to do is the turn
and what did you do is the dead I think
she's with grunkle Stan don't tell the
government about this and I'm just like
yeah she always looks stupid but she's
always completely correct why it's also
one except when it comes to boy bands at
that point then she becomes insane but I
think one of the reasons people like her
so much and worries is a life of her and
Stan is that they're both so confident
in them so you know standees company
he's an asshole he's a jerk and so on so
Frank it Mabel is just so calm - she's
happy doing whatever so they're my
favorite characters and soos Susan is
like in honestly if I were to rank them
I would probably go Mabel soos grunkle
Stan really I see Alex I like suit like
the stands in it more and I really like
his character but when soos has a line
it it's oftentimes it's like one of the
best lines in the show like he doesn't
say much he does have this amazing
delivery and it is it's like cuz it is
sort of repetitive it is it's always
gonna kind of be like
it's always kind of kind of be this
delivery but it still works like you
found that magic kind of formula that
that I had forgotten in the bottomless
pit episode that he had the best line
it's just like that what was the title
of his short it's just like I should
should be a pun I I don't know should be
a net I don't know the title says you
know the title and should it be a pun I
don't know how this exactly works I mean
whatever it was but like yeah so I I
gotta go with Mabel first because now
she's amazing freakin Mabel and uh yeah
then I would probably go soos and
grunkle Stan like but I again I have
nothing against I don't have anything
really against Wendy she's really oh
she's a fine alliance I've warmed up to
her a lot um I I really like I don't
have anything against dipper but it's
just like those other three characters
just for me completely sell the show I
mean I guess dippers problem is you need
a straight guy in a show and he's
history has to be this way yeah so and I
was even for a straight guy I mean it's
like he's pretty funny I mean it's like
the delivery choice he does perfect way
needs to do but yet you need you need
your Harry Potter you need your froat
obey you need someone that's gonna be
the person to work off of everybody oh
oh oh I called it it was invisible ink
yeah no see my dog in that video like ya
know I marry you so that was just sort
of like that's what I like when I guess
that Korra was gonna ever powers take it
away you just said that will go so to
say if you go back in that video just
are like that yeah they try not to give
it anyway
yeah no totally Cola I didn't know that
backlight would bring it out but like I
I love it I love I love this kind of
stuff I mean it's like I said any I do
think aventure time is technically a
better more creative show but it's like
this is so up my alley like the little
secrets and the puzzles in this sort of
creepy forest that has all sorts of
monsters and creatures I really love it
- the funny thing though is like I'm
kind of like Mabel I'm kind of in it for
the jokes and just the fun I love both
equally I don't want like the mysteries
fine I am but like as I'm watching it
I'm like I'm not into trying to solve
the mystery I'm just into
for the ride no really advance one
advance when the problems with like lost
is that I'm not gonna say the characters
were bad they were good you really would
not watch the show it if the characters
weren't good but everybody was in it for
the mystery from like day one it's like
no this is the focus as a mystery and
when they don't deliver you get really
pissed off honestly even if this one
pulled like a loss to didn't explain
half the the question I'd be pissed off
I still be like I'm still really glad I
invested time in that show and I would
watch like any of these episodes again
because they're just so enjoyed no this
actually is one of my new favorite
episodes just I love the atmosphere I
love the lighting I love one yeah the
animation was great the lighting was
really effective lots of reds and greens
it's a very high shadows yes um how to I
love love patrol alpha like just any
scene with Mabel I said I just BFFs
forever uh yeah I don't know what else
we're probably rambling on on this one
so a lot better to get through so this
is a really solid episode and um I will
say this I have not read dipper goes to
Taco Bell I have had enough glare we've
come I've had enough I've had enough
people describe it to me
that all I can say is after all this
build-up Hermer here Jerry Jerry she
talked about are you guys favorite it's
just a glorified aristocrats joke
without a punchline Internet I am
disappoint I am really disappointed you
can get way more creative than that
that's not gonna just fit that's ain't
gonna come close by maybe sometime I
will read it just so I can be like well
they're there wave us twincest if this
is your follow up yeah this is your
follow up you want something that you
want something worse I'll tell you what
and don't do this if you don't want the
show ruined for you but go to youtube
type Christian shawl funny stand up and
the yeah and the first one you see where
Kristen Charles doing her stand-up and
she's talking about her taint close your
eyes and imagine Maybelle delivering all
of those lines that'll ruin the show for
you prettier Mabel talk about
yeah dipper goes to Taco Bell yeah I was
like but once I found out like I didn't
realize it was Kristen Schaal like to
begin with in like a few episodes and I
saw that I'm like oh my god
cuz like I'd seen her stuff on the daily
show and I see my burgers well I kind of
forgot like oh you just for some reason
the voice wasn't clicking in my head
because I maybe it's cuz she's playing a
little kid in this I wasn't attaching it
to her adult like you know I can see is
the person anytime yeah Mabel but yeah
and now like all I can see is that whole
routine she did talking about her taint
at the mirror that uh oh yeah you want
it you wanna friend you want ever if
somebody gives you dipper goes to Taco
Bell is like this is gonna mess you up
like tell them to do that tell them do
that cuz that messed me up way more
because it's her real voice so yeah
there's very little put on for from able
voice it really is like her by which I
at no offense to the actress or whatever
I really thought she was doing like you
know a little bit of a Molly no that's a
real boy that's a natural that's what
she's so perfect if you see her stand-up
routine and her will verify she's very
funny yeah and she's kind of like me oh
it's got this weird sort o she's totally
worried as you're very now weird yes
marred so perfect casting danda no I am
really really good stuff yeah um Oh
other than that no sweater it's kind of
sad but hey at least I still got a
waddles Appa or Tzadik to call him WAPA
see you next time
same taped channel website taped then
why'd you have to bring that up